no queda nada del refugio improvisado
donde dormían las dos chicas bond aquel
en este asentamiento de las afueras de
durban con 11 y 17 años fueron
arrastradas el pasado lunes por un
corrimiento de tierras su madre estaba
temporalmente ausente cuando volví
pregunté dónde estaban mis hijas les
dije que se quedaran con mi hermana
nadie pudo responder me le pregunté a mi
hijo y no pudo decírmelo solo entonces
comprendí que habían sido arrastradas
por la inundación como esta familia
afligida otros cientos han perdido a sus
seres queridos decenas de miles de
personas se han visto afectadas víctimas
de las mortales inundaciones que azotan
la región desde el pasado lunes
estoy triste pero no puedo enfadarme con
nadie es la voluntad de dios
[Música]
las ceremonias de la pascua cristiana ya
han comenzado y para algunos es una
oportunidad para enviar un mensaje de
esperanza y hay tantas razones para
desesperarse en estos tiempos pero el
mensaje cristiano es inmenso ante la
oscuridad hay luz incluso ante la
desesperación hay esperanza
para este fin de semana se prevé más mal
tiempo en gran parte de la provincia
esto complicará a la tarea de los
rescatistas y podrían causar más
derrumbes de inundaciones